[Music]
hello and welcome everybody to the total
soccer show live on the br app my name
is taylor rockwell on today's show we're
breaking down the world cup draw live
we've got the world cup draw happening
the usa is in it which is obviously the
most important thing for everyone
involved to break down that draw i'm
joined by two wonderful gentlemen
or one gentleman and one joe lowry
graham are you comfortable with being
the show's channel
uh yeah i guess i don't think i've ever
been described as a gentleman i don't
think any scottish person ever in
history has been described as a
gentleman before but yeah i'll take it
for today thanks
uh yeah i like the idea of graham as the
scottish gentleman which joe i believe
that makes you the bad boy outsider that
seems totally fitting for you
oh yeah you guys know me i'm all about
that bad boy vibe i think it's perfect
casting from you taylor great great job
i i try i try ryan bailey uh is not with
us today but the three of us will be
breaking down the draw as i said both of
you are in pot a in my heart for being
here today speaking of pots we've got
four of them eight teams in each one all
of them decided by their fifa
coefficient ranking uh except for qatar
the host nation they are obviously the
first team that will be selected they're
going right into group a
we're going to start with pot one each
team gets assigned to a group then we go
to part two and the same thing happens
with two and three and four it works
just like that uh once we have all of
our groups we will then know which is
the group of death and which one the
united states is going to win the only
other rules would be
every group will have at least one
european team five groups will have two
european teams other than europe no
confederation can have more than one
team in a group graham ruffin can you
take us through part one please
yeah sure so part one as you say they
are sorted by rankings you have guitar
in there as the host nations just to uh
to shake things up a little bit so you
have brazil and the most successful
nation in world cup men's world cup
history you have belgium you have france
of course the defending champions from
2018 you have argentina you have england
spain and portugal as well
all right we've got pot one there we're
gonna obviously be talking more about
those teams as they are assigned joe
lowery can you take us through part two
i will in just one second taylor i can't
believe we haven't yet stopped to
address the ryan bailey cardboard cutout
that graeme ruthman is showing on screen
it is darn right beautiful i i graham i
love you so much for doing that ryan
always with us even in our hearts
um okay little ryan
let's let's see uh what he's got to say
oh uh okay charlotte charlotte fcr won
an mls cup and
he's asking me where the nearest hard
rock cafe is so yeah it definitely has a
little brian bailey here and
wait graham how did you make that and
how did you get the most perfect face
for the ryan bailey cutouts
uh i mean it wasn't difficult to this is
his general expression this is his
resting ryan face
[Laughter]
so oh my god
oh my god i'm so happy right now that's
beautiful
that's amazing thank you graeme
you're here with us you're here with us
okay part two ladies and gentlemen part
two the netherlands are in part two
along with germany
denmark switzerland croatia uruguay the
united states and mexico so those are
your top those are your eight teams
they're right after the top pot in terms
of the fifa rankings
usa ranked ahead of netherlands in
germany that feels totally appropriate
and accurate uh graham how about part
three
in part three we have senegal of course
recently one
afghan after a couple nations we have
iran we have a japan
we have morocco serbia poland who came
through the playoffs in uefa south korea
and finally canada of course our table
toppers in concacaf in this psycho well
done to canada their first appearance at
a world cup since
1986 then graham you had i think what
like a 15 minute presentation there
abouts about like all of the historical
connections between the countries in pot
3 and how they're all going to play out
right
oh yeah absolutely just the correction
there by the way canada and my notes i
incorrectly have them in part three they
are actually number four the team that
is uh in their places as tunisia and
pottery apologies for that i think that
was a late change in the qualification
cycle they were due to be in part three
but they are actually in pot for
clarification there
i'm choosing to believe number one that
that was a troll job but number two
because you're trolling canada i'm
taking away the 15-minute presentation
that you've worked so hard on instead
we'll just have to talk about the
individual teams as a group
[Laughter]
uh joe pot four if you would
you got it so canada as graham said are
in pot four they were stuck there after
they they couldn't get a result uh the
result they needed on the last day of
concacaf world cup qualifying so you got
canada cameroon ecuador saudi arabia
ghana and then we have some of the
playoffs here so these are the teams
that have yet to be decided
as to whether they'll actually be in the
world cup or not so you have the
scotland ukraine wales contingent wales
is already through scotland still has
their game pending versus ukraine and
we're not entirely sure when that's
going to be taking place but one of
those three teams will be in pot four
along with australia um or the uae or
peru right so there's action there still
to be played and then the final spot
between the fourth place team in
concacaf and the winner of oceana is
costa rica versus new zealand costa rica
being pretty heavy favorites there but
maybe we'll talk more about that matchup
later on
i think as we're waiting for fifa to
take its jolly old time to get the draw
going because shock of all shocks fifa
do things according to their own
schedule uh let's stick with those
playoffs if we could for a moment
specifically graham i wanted to ask you
i think we've talked plenty about how
you're sort of feeling about the
situation trying like waiting for the
scotland ukraine game then ideally
advancing to wales but before everything
happened when the draw first was
announced when you knew you were going
to be playing ukraine and then
potentially wales how did you feel about
that draw how did you feel about going
up against ukraine before the invasion
by russia
yeah so it was actually one of the the
more favorable draws i think we we could
have had scotland amazingly i don't
quite know how it happened but we were
actually one of the seated teams for the
playoffs along with the likes of
portugal and italy and a lot of the a
lot of the good teams we were up there
with them as one of the seeds so we got
ukraine which were meant to get a
slightly more favorable draw from that
ukraine obviously facing a whole lot of
stuff at the moment which is uh which
transcends soccer and i'm sure they're
their national team aren't even thinking
about that playoff game understandably
so at the moment but in terms of their
their soccer team um i think that's an
even uneven battle between ukraine and
scotland but i would find for chances at
home wales in the final i think we are a
better team as a whole than wales but
they've got that certain uh real winger
who can produce something out of nothing
and he makes me very very nervous so i
do hope that we get to that game but at
the moment it feels a little bit um
irrelevant at the moment it's a strange
feeling kind of watching scotland
technically being in this draw today and
not really knowing what's happening with
with our path to or ukraine's path or
wales his path to this tournament
yeah i imagine it's very much not fun
the fun thing i guess for me and joe
would be if we do end up potentially
getting uh the winner of that playoff
series into the usa's group uh we talked
about this on the show this week but it
would be very fun to get maybe even an
england uh usa scotland group for tss
interests though i think that might also
uh tear us apart and i think plenty of
people took twitter to point out that
there was a statistical possibility or a
not likelihood but a strong percentage
chance that the united states does end
up in a group with the winner of that
scotland ukraine wales playoff
graham if you had to play the united
states and i'm gonna i'm gonna say based
solely to make it even more confusing on
the last two games you saw from them
versus panama and then versus costa rica
how are you scotland feeling about that
one
um okay with the costa rica game i think
but not so okay with the panama game
there seemed to be quite a a difference
in performance levels between those
those two performance but to be to be
honest and and not to throw any shade at
the us or concacaf out of the the part
two teams of scotland do get through to
the the tournament itself i think the
usa and and mexico probably would be the
two teams that i personally would pick
out of i mean i would like that a an
american and draw in our group versus
scotland for tss reasons but i i do
think it's a teammate of part two when
you look at you know germany and
netherlands and even denmark who we had
in our qualification group and where we
did beat denmark but they're a very very
good team i think the us still feels
like a bit of a work in progress
slightly in mexico even though they they
actually finished the qualification
campaign relatively well
there's a bit of disgruntlement under
tata martino and they don't really know
how they're playing there's not much of
an identity there so the us and mexico
for me
again not throwing any shade but there
may be slightly weaker teams in that in
that pot too but i was thinking this
before
the the looking at the the pots and
before the draw there's not a lot
between a lot of the pots and because
obviously they have changed this
recently in terms of how they're how
they're doing the party used to be done
by region not so long ago so now it's by
ranking but even with rankings you know
part two you've got germany and
netherlands and part two they could
easily be pop one teams senegal and
serbia in port in part three cameroon
ecuador and ghana and and pot four these
are high quality teams and some of the
lower parts so i do think that is very
very even across the across the split
with the pots
so joe we're we're getting our our hosts
out on the stage one by one i would say
very slowly which gives us some time to
take some questions from twitter one
comes to us from at tony three the
number three flash
mexico and us will not advance out of
the first round disagree uh i need a
third team to root for maybe canada
question mark says tony three flash
i'm i'm not at all opposed to rooting on
canada in this particular competition i
generally take the concacaf overall
approach at least in terms of rooting
interest if i'm looking for some in
canada i wrote this for the athletic you
know a couple of months ago i think
they're a pretty likable team filled
with a lot of really impressive players
alfonzo davies of course is their
talisman they have talent up front with
kyle laron who plays in turkey and maybe
moving this summer jonathan david who
plays for leyland and probably will be
moving this summer they have a really
nice number six and stephan estakio who
just moved to porto in the winter window
on loan there's a ton of talent here
there's mls tie-ins as well in that back
line
canada are a good team filled with very
good players and in what's more under
john herdman i think the style they play
which is
generally and this is a very simplified
way to phrase it but they're trying to
frustrate right they're trying to make
you
hit your head against the wall over and
over again win the ball and then attack
quickly after they win it through their
extremely talented players dejan
buchanan another one of course that i
didn't mention there so yeah i mean
taylor i think i think if if you're
looking for a team to root for and if
you don't think the us and mexico are
going to do well in this competition
canada are pretty high on that list
uh
sticking with our specifically u.s
interests for a moment joe at
mightymouse1371
asks how bad will the u.s be screwed i
might even disagree with that one
because i think as we pointed out these
spots are pretty
pretty balanced not not like an obvious
one in my mind for a group of death but
do you have any concerns for the united
states with this draw
it's too early to tell like it's too
early right now there's absolutely a
chance that the us gets a brutal group
like you could end up with
i don't know one of the european teams
in pot one which means you can still
have another european team later in
their depths
with these european groups although not
not as many european teams as you go
down through the pots but then you could
end up with a team like ecuador in that
last pot right who are extremely strong
and you can end up with senegal from
prop from pot 3 who i think are maybe
the best team in that pot i mean there's
there's absolutely a chance that the us
gets a brutal draw but that's that's
true for most teams right the the one
thing the us that we do know about this
us team is that they won't be able to
draw canada from pop four which i think
is a huge thing for them you can't draw
unless you're in uefa another team from
your confederation in this world cup
taylor as you already mentioned so that
is a good thing for the u.s because i
just did a whole spiel on canada i think
they're a really good team that is
potentially poised to make it out of
their group even against some stout
competition and maybe even make a little
bit of a run in this competition taylor
agreed and because the united states has
found its way into plot two thankfully i
think historically they have not and so
if they were in say pot three or in pot
four as canada is then there's that
possibility that you get say brazil and
germany out of pot one and part two that
would be a rough draw but since the us
is in part two they avoid the
netherlands germany croatia uruguay
mexico obviously some of the stronger
teams switzerland having handed the us a
defeat previously graham uh from a u.s
perspective is there a team in pot one
you think they should be most wanting to
avoid i'm assuming the answer is brazil
uh yes brazil looked very
very strong they went through calling
the ball qualifying unbeaten obviously
there is still that strange game against
argentina that was uh postponed due to
players being dragged off the pitch in
the middle of the the covered pandemic
that was that was uh that was a weird
fever dream of a match that's still to
be resolved but so far that they have
gone through that campaign um be
unbeaten and cheated the the manager has
done a very good job of adding structure
to a team that is stacked with options i
mean i think only
france you would say um have the depth
that brazil have just to run through
some of their key players you know
neymar vinicius jr one of your favorites
joe anthony of iaxfame marquinhos
fabinho coutinho they have players
throughout that team i mean thiago silva
phil backs in the form of danilo and
alex sandro and they just have so many
options across that across the pitch and
uh yeah i think that is in the past
brazil have always had good squads
they had a good squad in 2018 but it
just felt like they maybe didn't have
the structure to compete or at least
compete at their best in knockout
football and knockout formats that's
kind of changed now it feels like they
have got that structure that as i say
the manager chuche has has kind of got
everyone to buy into that structure in
the past dunga tried to do it with
brazil and faced a lot of pushback from
brazilian fans who said this is not how
we play i think brazil have now had
enough failures in a row since 2002 keep
in mind that's the last time they won
the world cup they've had enough
failures in succession to get fans to
buy into this idea that they need a
little bit more than just jogger beetle
and flare and we might see that from
them at this world cup
and joe for you is brazil the team you
would most like to avoid or is there
anybody else in pot one that you're
particularly nervous if we end up at a
group with
argentina as well uh i think both of
those south american giants are are
certainly teams that you want to avoid
but that goes for a lot of teams in that
pod i think qatar is certainly the team
that you want to be paired with in that
first group right i mean they are the
weakest team that's not to say they're a
bad team and maybe we'll talk more about
them as they actually get going in this
draw there's a lot of talent there under
felix sanchez and they play some good
soccer as the us saw in the gold cup
this past summer but argentina scared me
because of a of a little man named leila
messi right there's a theme
in this tournament and i certainly don't
want to reduce argentina or any team in
this tournament to just one player but
you think about teams that have one
dominant name right poland with robert
lewandowski uh morocco with akra fakimi
messi and argentina like these are
players that can sink you right in in a
one-off tournament where luck is a huge
factor you know taylor you and i talk so
much about greg barother and what he's
trying to build with the national team
and how they're playing tactically and i
love that stuff right and i know you do
too but sometimes in tournament play
like that goes out the window out the
window it is a great equalizer turned
into a southern southern gentleman there
for this time that's graham's job all
right not the gentleman on this show we
already established that
but like that's that's the equalizer
right tournament soccer is a giant
leveler across the world that's what
makes the world cup so much fun because
you can see france get knocked out in
the euros and they did you can see spain
go out i mean so many different things
can happen and when you have the best
player who's ever played this silly game
on your team and leola messi you
immediately scare me and make me want to
uh to run for the hill so argentina
certainly i mean i think in terms of
teams that i would most like to see
end up in the us's group from pot one
qatar is far and away uh the team that i
think i think would be the weakest and
so therefore the best for the u.s
portugal would probably be the next one
uh i don't think they're all that
exceptional to watch under fernando
santos they're not all that expensive or
exciting and they play like less than
the sum of their parts again so much
talent cristiano ronaldo bruno fernandez
bernardo silva like the list goes on and
on and on they're one of the most
talented teams in this tournament but
because of how they play and because of
how i do think santos handicaps this
team i i think that could be a decent
draw for the us as well
joe you mentioned
experience there
uh
sorry taylor yeah you mentioned the
tournament experience there i think with
the ux that's going to be a really
interesting thing for them because
speaking as a scotland fan we got to the
euros after a long wait we had a young
team and then when we got to the euros
it became clear that we lacked a whole
load of experience and we were very
naive in games a lot has been made about
this the the age the youth of this usmt
side
and i just wonder if maybe that will be
something that counts against them when
the tournament actually uh gets started
having said that there are a lot of
players in that team who are playing at
high level in europe at big clubs so
maybe maybe not so much but i guess
we'll find out well
in graham it's not even just the players
right for the us it's also greg peralta
you know let's not forget that this is
yeah he's still relatively new
again i want to almost put an asterisk
there because it's been since you know
it's been it's been years now but he's
still relatively new to international
management right like he's never managed
at a world cup before certainly and that
goes for other managers in this
competition as well but we saw some of
that naivety at the start of the world
cup qualifying campaign with tyler adams
coming out and saying we want this to be
a nine-point window and i think in some
senses he was absolutely justified to
say that that should be the goal for for
any team to go out and win every single
game that's in front of them but i think
we could see some of that naivete from
from great broader and from this team i
do think that world cup qualifying and
this expanded conquer catholic
qualifying campaign probably takes some
of that naivety away and this team
certainly has more reps now together and
has been through a really weird and
challenging three window world cup
qualifying campaign so i think that will
help but graham i think that's
absolutely a story line the inexperience
of this team as they head into the world
cup
uh in the meantime we have started the
draw we have got qatar drawn into group
one uh group position one so they're in
a1 congratulations to guitar who knew
that was happening
we've now had england
drawn up next
uh we're gonna see where they end up but
we've got england in group b um
ryan bailey not here with us to discuss
uh how strong england could potentially
be but graham they've been building
tournament on tournament are you
expecting this to be the one where they
make the final again and then don't win
uh yep little ryan bailey is just saying
a few things to me so he's saying diego
maradona is a villain
96 1966 was the best world cup one of
all time and england are going out in
the group stage well one of those things
is certainly true little ryan bailey um
yeah to be serious though there is a
sense that england have been building
towards this tournament for a while they
made the semi-finals in 2018 obviously
in the euros they make the final as well
and i always think with england part of
the battle is
just getting everyone pulling in the one
direction as as part of the battle for
england they've had national team
managers who have not been very popular
with players with fans gareth southgate
is very popular i think he has done a
great job of getting all those players
on the same page he speaks very well and
questions about him as a tactician i
think at the euros and they were
slightly too compact and conservative
good considering the amount of attacking
creative talent that they have i think
that's going to be a storyline for
england at this tournament as can they
liberate some of that that attacking
talent a little bit do they really need
to play declan rice and calvin phillips
as a midfield anchor in the same team
can they free up one of those positions
to uh phil foden or amazing man
slightly further up the pitch but in
terms of the the talent england have you
can't you can't really doubt the talent
that they've got you know harry kane
raheem sterling jack grealish as i say
foden mount all the way through that
team top quality players about every
right back in the world plays for
england at the moment um so yes a high
quality team with a good track record
recently who should be looking to make a
deep run at this tournament if not win
this whole tournament
all right we're gonna do some catching
up here so we've got england in group b
in group c we've got argentina and we've
just had france placed into group d for
people watching at home or watching the
draw live you might see you're getting
the countries drawn then the secondary
draw you've got like the red ball
because all of these top seeds are gonna
get that first position then after that
it's a bit random as i understand it but
we now have spain
drawn into group e so to recap qatar in
a england in b argentina c france d and
spain e
uh
graham did you have any thoughts on
argentina being in a particularly strong
run of form
yeah so they're on a 30-game unbeaten
run at the moment argentina which is the
longest in international soccer right
now after italy imploded
following their what was it 37
game run and of course they are not at
this tournament after being beaten by
north macedonia in the playoffs but
argentina certainly looks stronger for
this tournament than they have
for a while certainly since 2014 when
they they made the final and actually in
terms of their individual quality and
their qualification campaign i'd say
they're even stronger than they were in
in 2014. of course we have to mention
leo messi potentially the best player in
the world right now certainly the best
player in the world over the last 10 15
years still a big figure for this
argentina team but what leno scaloni the
head coach has done for this team is
he's found him support so it's not all
on it's not all on him you know la taro
martinez that midfield unit i i like a
lot with giovanni la salso and leando
paredes and they they they provide a lot
of support for the front line with di
maria and martinez and messi up there
so i i do expect they've kind of had the
limelight stolen from them argentina by
brazil who had an exceptional common
ball qualification campaign but they've
still been very very solid and very
impressive by finishing a comfortable
second in that table
so uh we've got
spain in group e we've moved on to group
f which now has belgium group g which
has brazil and that will mean portugal
goes into group h that has not happened
yet as i understand the draw to be
taking place but
portugal into group h
joe if you're looking at those where are
you hoping the united states is ending
up if we've got qatar in a england b
argentina c france d
spain e belgium f brazil g portugal h
yeah group a is the money group that's
well and maybe more ways than one in a
certain sense that was unintentional but
i think that's exactly where you want to
be if you're any team in this
competition i want to pause quickly on
qatar because i think they're far and
away the team that you do want to be
placed with just because of the
difference between them and the the
actual top seven teams in the fifa
rankings but man
i think there will be as we head towards
the world cup a narrative of this guitar
team doesn't know what they're doing
they have no business being in this
competition and there's some potential
merit for that in terms of the country
hosting this of course but in terms of
the actual team this is a very legit
talented soccer team coach by spanish
manager felix sanchez they're very
defined in how they play they have a
clear identity in what they're doing
they play out of this five three two
three five two shape they've got a a
strong number nine and then they'll have
akram afif who is their star and and for
me he's one of my picks to be a genuine
standout in this tournament like uh
hamas rodriguez at a past world cup kind
of moment he's not james rodriguez but
he is really really good as that number
10. u.s fans might remember that from
the gold cup semifinal that they played
against guitar and really all throughout
that tournament in qatar obviously i
mentioned they play in the gold cup
that's not a normal thing for a team
from that region to be flying all the
way across to north and central america
guitars played
concacaf teams they played con my bowl
teams they've played uefa teams like
this team has done about everything they
can to prepare for this competition in
addition to being recent champions of
asia as well like they've put in a lot
of preparation from a sporting
standpoint
to be able to compete in this in this
whole world cup so i'm not saying that
they should be favorites i i wouldn't be
surprised though if they make it out of
a group like this is a strong team
that's very well coached they're well
drilled defensively they have creativity
especially with that thief but man even
some of the rotations like they're a
modern soccer team you could you could
look and see them really be effective on
the world stage so guitar i think is the
team that's going to be easiest uh to
make it past in terms of these one seeds
but i i wouldn't be upset if the us
ended up with portugal or ended up with
england at least for the for the tss
narrative there
graham we've got netherlands now drawn
placed into group a they're gonna be in
the fourth position in group a they've
got virgil van dyke back for this
tournament uh are you expecting that to
be a difference maker for them
yeah i think it will be because
obviously van dijk misses the euros last
summer through injury and you could say
he's probably the best central defender
and
in european football right now world
football right now but uh
obviously netherlands missed the last
tournament um through not qualifying for
for the world cup and ronald ronald
coleman did a good job of of getting him
back on the right track then he left for
barcelona then frank deboer came in uh
stopped me if you've heard this before
with frank the bear didn't do such a
good job with stacked and now louis van
gaal is in charge of the netherlands and
they they've got a good team you know
roger van dyke frankie the young memphis
de paris a key player for them matthias
delet denzel dumfries we saw glimpses of
what they could do at the euros before
obviously they suffered a shock defeat
to the czech republic but i still expect
a good showing from the netherlands in
this tournament i'm going to stop now
because i feel like he may have come out
of a pot and may have entered a certain
group
the united states in b3 position with
england joe we get england
we're wow two-thirds of the way towards
getting to css darby
we're basically halfway to a usa england
game on thanksgiving morning like i mean
this is it doesn't really get any better
than this guys i mean this is this is
crazy right from a narrative perspective
the usa and england certainly have a
rivalry there even in a world cup sense
i think these are our
this is going to be a really strong
match up i'm excited selfishly for us as
we look forward to this group stage game
we'll have ryan obviously reacting to
this on dss i'm sure in the near future
taylor i really want to get your
perspective here because you certainly
have more of a background with the
rivalry between the us and england than
i do beyond just the beautiful narrative
that we have internally what do you
think of this matchup and what does this
really mean for the us
i mean they must be destroyed is the
obvious answer uh i think i think it is
a good matchup obviously it's england a
very strong team with a ton of depth and
talent
but i will say i do not fear england as
an attacking unit i think the key to
their euro performance was that
stability the defensive stability the
midfield base it'll be very difficult
for the united states to find a way
through that but you you mark harry kane
you don't give him space in the box you
don't let him dive wink wink uh and i
think it's going to be a really really
interesting matchup for the united
states i am super excited about that one
i am super excited about group c in
which we now have mexico into the third
position argentina mexico i think that's
the 2002 world cup was it that was a
pretty solid uh game in that one i look
forward to that matchup graham how you
feeling about mexico
mexico are a strange one right now
because obviously they finished that
camp campaign pretty strongly but as i
said earlier there's there's a lot of uh
doubt from their fans about the
direction that they're they're heading
in but if you look at the individual
talent i know there's a slightly aging
group at the moment but
you've still got players like raul
jimenez hector herrera edson alvarez
chuckles chucky lozano takatito and
corona that front three in particular if
tata martino can get them firing at the
world cup that that's the sort of thing
that could get them past the the fifth
game which is obviously the big thing
from mexico they keep they keep talking
about uh the quinto partido the fifth
game as they call it they've never been
past the quarter finals they want to
make the semi-finals this mexico team
feels like particularly having dropped
into that group with argentina that's
that's a difficult one for them but it
feels like maybe this mexico team
doesn't stand the best chance of that in
terms of going back through past
tournaments but the world cup does funny
things i don't think england expected to
make the semi-finals in 2018 so maybe
mexico do it this year
uh the world cup does do funny things so
too does the world cup draw we've had
denmark drawn into group d alongside
france and i think we've got a group of
death potential in the making because in
group e joining spain yeah would be
germany
joe germany spain
i'm interested in how that one's gonna
go because it could be the opener and
maybe that won't be that interesting but
i think because it's gonna be first
versus third we'll get that as like a
second game so we get sure the initial
sort of tension wearing off and then
we're gonna get i'm hoping an expansive
really fun game yeah i mean tons of
talent there right spain are gonna want
to take the joy out of that game in the
very spanish way that they often try to
do that right we saw this with the euros
we've seen this in the past but luis
enrique is is trying to get this team to
completely dominate the ball in germany
they are more willing to play in
transition they also like to have their
fair share of the ball and i imagine
they'll have some of it in this game but
that's that's what's going to make this
one so interesting for me of course you
have all of the talent on the field tons
of massive names on both sides of this
of this game that we'll see in the group
stage but man spain are going to want to
dominate the ball and pin germany back
and break through them how do germany
respond to that like i mean i'm already
itching to talk more about this and see
games like this unfold and even to go
back one group taylor quickly france and
denmark like that's another really fun
one in group d francis the team from pot
one denmark from part two graham you
mentioned i mean you saw them up close
when they're in scotland's group in
qualifying in uefa this is a good team
and of course there's the narrative of
christian erickson coming back and he
scored goals recently for denmark which
has been incredible to see but denmark
play really really good soccer under
casper gilman and france maybe don't
play that but what they lack in tactical
excellence they certainly make up for
with killian ambape and karim benzema
and all of the other talented players
that they have that's another really fun
matchup taylor
uh agreed entirely my friend joe i want
to get your thoughts on croatia drawn
into a group with uh belgium in group f
but we've also had uh uruguay was the
next uh team selected national team
selected they would have been placed
into group g but that features brazil
you can't have two commable teams so we
now have uruguay moving into uh
portugal's group group h uh they will be
in the third position there joe do you
think belgium may be pleased to get
croatia in their group
i think so for for my money croatia are
agreement you talked about the us and
mexico maybe being towards the bottom of
pot 2 and in terms of fifa rankings
you're absolutely right i just wasn't
impressed with croatia at the euros and
maybe you guys disagree but i think this
is an aging team at this point like they
are still luka modric's team and he is
still a phenomenal player as we've seen
with real madrid as they make their run
in the champions league and as they
still have a lead in la liga he's unreal
to watch but they don't have a ton of
really well organized structure under
zlatko dalich they don't they don't wow
me and they didn't impress me at the
euros and i don't know that this team is
a real threat like for me this group f
with belgium and croatia whoever ends up
being drawn in pot3 which won't be a
european team it'll be a team from any
other confederation because they already
have two i think you're licking your
lips a little bit because you see
croatia as a team that you can beat like
they didn't look invincible in the euros
i know they made a run to the world cup
final in the last edition of this
competition but it's just not the same
team for me at this point
it is not the same croatian team but it
has luca muldrich in it so they might
just end up winning the whole thing
because he tends to win uh we've got
brazil and switzerland in group g
commiserations to switzerland who
thought they'd avoided brazil and then
nope the way the luck of the draw works
they bounce into group g uruguay into
the final group with portugal and we
move into pot 3 teams i'm just gonna uh
vamp for a moment we had a question
about which african team did we i we
most want the united states to avoid my
answer would be senegal and they have
not done that yet uh but we have had the
first draw out of pot three iran goes
into a group with qatar and the
netherlands but i believe that would put
two teams from the same confederation in
once again so we may have iran then
bouncing into the usa's group
that's gonna be an interesting one
[Laughter]
um that did not go so well for the
united states yeah right
oh boy oh boy indeed uh yeah taylor what
do you think not well
what do you think of that from a
sporting perspective like i mean i don't
know that iran is is going to be a team
that a lot of folks out there are super
familiar with do you think this is a
good draw even just based off the other
teams in pot 3. like i think the fact
from for me that the us avoided senegal
and and even morocco maybe and some of
these other teams is a bit of a boon is
that is that the wrong perspective
i i don't think it is joe i think i
think you're right on there i think this
is obviously going to be a very strong
iran team uh they topped their afc group
eight wins one draw one loss a goal
difference of plus 11 and when you only
concede four goals in all of qualifying
that's a pretty good start uh but
they've got some talent in there as well
when it comes to the attack uh there's
ali reza jahanbach formerly of brighton
there's mehdi taremi of fc porto uh and
they've got sarah azmoon of bayer
leverkusen he added three goals in
qualifying he was their top scorer uh
excuse me their third top score in
qualifying but he is their all-time top
scorer in the champions league coached
by dragon skosich 50 53 year old excuse
me croatian
took over in february of 2020 managed in
croatia in the middle east he's a
veteran manager but i believe this will
be his first world cup
and he's gonna have quite the test ahead
of him with iran versus the united
states and then england in there as well
i'm nervous about some of those uh
historical connections graham do you
think the us should be uh pleased with
this one
yeah generally speaking yes but i
actually did a world cup preview of iran
uh before the draw and iran of as you
say there finished top of the top of the
confederation you know it seemed to be i
have to say a lot of the players but
besides some of the obvious names there
you mentioned there taylor jahan bash
and and so on i'm not overly familiar
with they're not players i watch where
we can week out but it does seem like
they are a pretty strong unit as
illustrated by that defensive record you
you mentioned there and it does make me
worry slightly for the us that they
sometimes can stutter when facing a low
defensive block
if they face that in iran
then maybe that is the sort of game
where people look at iran i hope i'm not
being disrespectful they're not a you
know heavyweight soccer nation and
people go oh well that's three points on
the board maybe it's not maybe that's
quite a difficult match
i'm so excited the world cup's happening
uh joe a couple updates for us we did
have senegal get drawn uh they took
iran's place in group a iran goes into
group b senegal into a group with qatar
and the netherlands and we had poland
drawn into the group with argentina and
mexico poland in uh c4 position joe
would you rather talk about senegal or
poland
i'll do both quickly and just take a
quick look at both of these groups
man i don't think this could be going a
whole lot worse for qatar to be totally
honest i think the netherlands are one
of the strongest teams in pot two
certainly on talent you go through the
names that they have virgil van dijk
memphis depay frankie deyoung ryan grav
i mean the list goes on and on and on
the netherlands are stacked with talent
so that's a brutal draw for them as far
as the the pot 2 team in group a for
qatar and then they get senegal who are
a really strong team they beat uh egypt
in their playoff to make it and we got
the laser pointers and that whole thing
and really disgraceful behavior from the
senegal fans in that match but in terms
of what they have on the field like this
is a good team they made a pretty good
showing at the world cup in 2018 they
have again so much talent as many of
these teams do but they have legitimate
stars and one of course in sario mane
that almost everybody's gonna know so
that's a tough draw for guitar and then
in group c
this is shaping up to be quite the the
star-powered group right you have leno
messi in argentina now you have robert
lewandowski and po and poland joining
mexico i really like this group i think
from an entertainment perspective this
one is shaping out to be
quite good and not easy for any of these
teams really to get out of
uh
joe thank you for that we've had an
update to the draw senegal we're drawing
excuse me serbia serbia we're drawn next
they can't go into group d they can't
grow into group e or group f already too
many european teams so uh serbia join
brazil and switzerland in group g a
serbia team graham that we should maybe
be expecting some goals
from yeah absolutely what an attacking
unit that they are and before north
macedonia upstaged them in qualifying
serbia pulled off one of the the shocks
of uefa qualifying by finishing top of
their group ahead of portugal and they
did so with a dramatic winner in
portugal uh
alexander mitrovic scoring in the 90th
minute to send them through as the
automatic qualifiers from that that
group and that was that was no fluke you
know they went unbeaten through
qualifying as i say that's a group that
includes portugal a part one team and
they have a lot of individual quality
through the likes of dusan vladic who
obviously we've spoken a lot about on
the podcast juventus new number nine
they have alexander mitrovic who i
understand is maybe playing at a lower
level for his club but as a real
talisman for the serbia team and he
maybe doesn't start a lot of games but
he's very very useful to bring him off
the bench and provide an aerial threat
and just be a bit of a talisman du san
tadic obviously of a viax
milinkovic savage uh latio central
midfielder and the manager godoy the the
sevilla central midfielder so looking
through that team the spine of that team
from
the attack and i really really like that
attack where they have tadic filling a
lot of the space around vlavic and then
the link of it savage as the kind of
mobile
two-way central midfielder he's capable
of going both ways defensively and
offensively so there's lots to like
about the serbia team and i actually
think of all the teams in this world cup
draw they they're one that you maybe
want to avoid i certainly think that
group g with serbia the quality they
have switzerland with the tournament
experience that they have and then
brazil arguably the favorites that is
shaping up to be a very very strong
group
joe did you have anything there or
should we keep uh updating on the draw
we've had a few more teams come out
since then
yeah just i was just going to say
switzerland are a strong team as well um
they're more than just zaradan shakira
who of course is now playing with the
chicago fire they have talent that's
playing all over europe so that that
group g is going to be a tough one
indeed a few more updates what we'll do
maybe is just kind of keep live updating
the draw and then we'll revisit the
groups to give any additional thoughts
we might have but into group d with
france and denmark goes tunisia into the
fourth position there then in group e
we've had japan so we've got spain
germany and japan and now we have
morocco into group f waiting on the
position for them it's being unwound the
ball has been opened it's been lifted up
and we have morocco in the third
position there
joe morocco one of those teams you
mentioned previously that maybe will
rely on some individual performances
yeah i think
to avoid being overly reductive of of
course and i'll talk about maybe the
rest of their team in just a second but
they have a huge star they have a
talisman in akra fakimi who will just
blitz you down morocco's right and your
left like we saw this in afghan we see
it all the time for psg they're a team
that i think has a real shot not a top
not a pot one or a part two team so not
necessarily favorites to get out but i
talked about croatia being a pretty
favorable team as far as the pot twos go
i think morocco might be licking their
lips a little bit here they uh they
emerged from their two-legged playoff
over the dominican republic of the congo
they lost to egypt of course the
quarterfinals at afcon but this is a
pretty young team but they also have
some veterans and they have some
established players like kakimi there's
others here there's there's one i have
my eyes on uh ohana who plays for angers
in league uh he's a lovely ball
progresser on the dribble he's really
really talented and i want to make a
point to say like this is more than just
akraf akimi but it also certainly is
hakimi's team and i don't think belgium
or croatia are going to be all that
pleased about having morocco in their
group
no and i would agree with you joe
because i feel like that's what achara
faikimi is at club level it's like yeah
there's other players on the team
they're all very good but also at the
same time acha fakimi is probably the
best player uh we've finished out pot
three with uh korea going into group h
so portugal uruguay and korea and now we
have our pot four draw
we've got one intercontinental playoff
going into group a i am not sure which
one that is we'll try to get some
specifics on that one but we've got one
playoff team in group a so qatar
international playoff team senegal and
the netherlands in group a joe i don't
know if that one gets more tricky with
that one for for qatar but we would
assume they are
mostly okay with that draw all things
considered and now we have the final
team in uh group b coming up i'm very
very nervous about this one because it
could very well be ghana ghana still a
team that could be chosen and if we do
get ghana
england iran and ghana as opponents
feels like a ridiculous combination for
the u.s men's national team
i'm waiting i'm waiting the ball is
being opened i'm sort of terrified as to
what's about to happen here who who
knows gentlemen who knows what we're
gonna get
and it looks like we will get so ecuador
excuse me it seems like i guess the
international playoff team can't be
added to group a so the international
playoff game move to group d where they
will join france denmark and tunisia
i'm adding that to my notes kind of
confusing there and that means ecuador
goes into groups
poor qatar
in the netherlands
i i don't think that group could have
gotten any worse for qatar just then
like that is
i i don't think it's quite a group of
death maybe we can debate that in just a
second i guess it depends on how you
want to go about defining that but
ecuador i mean they finished uh they
finished fourth in commonwealth
qualifying which is no small feat we all
know how difficult it is to qualify from
call me bowl they finish behind of
course brazil and argentina and uruguay
they're coached by argentinian manager
gustavo alfaro and they're they're a
good team like they have a lot of really
strong players carlos griezo plays in
the bundesliga i mean really
well-rounded midfield they can play
vertically they secured a point against
both argentina and brazil already in
2022 like uh this is a strong team
taylor
what's going on here
thank you graeme uh
saudi arabia just just drawn uh but they
cannot be drawn into the group with the
united states that would feel too
ridiculously historically significant
instead saudi arabia moved into group uh
c joining argentina mexico and poland a
saudi team that is quite strong that's
another team that will probably not get
a ton of attention heading into the
tournament but they topped their
group in asian qualifying seven wins two
draws one loss leapfrogged japan on the
final day of qualifying and they are a
team composed of six clubs 27 players on
their most recent roster coming from six
total teams and really it's 24 players
from four clubs so you're getting a ton
of familiarity within that team within
that squad but i think we will get a
difficult team to play against a
difficult team to break down and i think
they're going to make that group
particularly exciting we now have
another playoff oh my goodness gentlemen
we might have gotten it we might have
gotten it here we have in group b i
believe we've got a playoff game
i think it's possible that we've got
scotland potentially if they go
we could have scotland that's
my
this is getting closer to
reality the tss grip of death
is getting pretty close now
do we have do we have any clarity on
which uh which of those playoffs like
which teams are those specific playoffs
obviously there's one drawn in group d
and now another in group b the group e1
can't be the european playoff because
there's already two european teams in
there so that has to be either costa
rica versus new zealand or one of
australia the uae in peru do we i'm not
sure that we know that yet am i talking
to my butt what's happening no joe i
think joe i think you're right it will
be the costa rica game and because of
that potential they get moved to group e
so that international playoff game that
could be costa rica could be new zealand
they are now in group e alongside spain
germany and japan
and instead we have the european playoff
it could be scotland scotland could
potentially be in the group with england
in the united states
if if they win
it will be the european playoff in that
final group
i cannot believe this actually happened
i cannot believe it's unreal potentially
have that
can you make your team win please so we
can have the most ridiculous world cup
possible
uh i mean
i feel like i shouldn't be throwing
shade at ukraine at this given time but
we need to win that uh that play off i
guess you train and get to this world
cup because that group is just
it's just too perfect i mean we said
that's what for tss purposes that would
be the perfect group and i cannot
believe it's actually it's actually come
out but yeah that would be interesting
england iran
usa and scotland obviously if we qualify
we should also mention that ukraine and
wales could come out of that come out of
that pathway and uh
yeah that would still be a very
interesting group i would say
it's it's a difficult one
to cuddle what's that this that's not an
easy draw obviously from a narrative
perspective it's it's great like that
european team we saw scotland compete
certainly at the at the euros ukraine
has a lot of talent i mean this is not
going to be easy and then grammy already
talked about wales with gareth bale the
narrative is phenomenal i'm not sure
that the u.s
got the best draw in terms of them
getting out of the group here but again
i'm not going to poo-poo what we've
already been talking about here this is
epic
epic indeed in the meantime we've got
cameroon drawn they cannot move into
group f so we'll instead get them into
group g so we've got brazil serbia
switzerland and cameroon cameroon
coached by one of my all-time favorites
riga bear song
i've said this already a couple times i
hope he's able to get a red card in this
one as strange as that sounds he needs
the record he's tied with zadon right
now for two red cards in two different
world cups he needs three and three
let's make it happen we have canada and
ghana still to be drawn and now ghana is
the next name up i believe they cannot
go into group f which would mean ghana
goes into group h joining portugal
uruguay and korea it's really nice to
have ghana back at a world cup it's been
i feel like a sort of downturn in form
for a ghana team that obviously plagued
the united states for two different
world cups that was fun
but to have them back topping their
group in the second round then
drawing nigeria getting the draw on the
road to basically win with the draw
courtesy of away goals the au brothers
continue to be a strong uh component for
this team and muhammad kudus is another
one to keep an eye on the 21 year old
midfielder for iax came through the
right to dream academy started with
norjaland moved to ix as an 18 year old
for 9 million euros and is such an
exciting player such an exciting talent
and joe the ix connection i know has to
make you happy
oh of course yeah i love the different
ix bits we have popping up we see that
especially in group c graham oh no no
excuse me not in group c but we do have
mexico and it's now as in group c
anthony and brazil and group g taylor
talking about that connection there in
group h yeah let's let's just get all
the iax players in this thing
and rounding it out we've got our woke
up draw group f belgium canada morocco
and croatia
that's a tough one i think for canada
belgium going to be very tricky morocco
going to be very tricky croatia
potentially tricky unless joe lowry gets
his way and then they crumble and canada
makes it through
joe how do you think canadians are
feeling about that one
i think they've got to be feeling pretty
good right i mean belgium of course is a
really strong team morocco i mentioned
with akra fakimi being a real challenge
there and of course the other talent
they have
but i don't think this is a bad draw for
canada at all i don't think they ended
up with like the strongest african team
they didn't end up with the strongest
pot 3 team and i really as i've stated i
don't think they ended up with with a
particularly strong pot two team i think
they've got a real shot here guys which
has got to be hugely exciting for canada
after they kind of bottled being in pot
three on the last day of work
qualification in concacaf that could
have been really costly and i think all
things considered it played out pretty
well for him here
i'd i'd even say their part one team i
know this is slightly strange to say
about a team that's ranked number two in
in the world but belgium feels like
they're kind of coming to the end of a
cycle i've never been that convinced by
roberto martinez either as the national
team boss there they've got a lot of
aging players yes okay they do have kim
de bruyne and ramel lukaku who i think
has scored i've got the record here 68
goals and 101 caps that's not bad so
canada need to be wary of of those guys
but i think it would have been worse if
they'd got a brazil or in fact to be
honest looking through all those pot one
teams you know guitars maybe they're the
only one that i would say i i would kind
of fancy canada having a shot against
belgium like that that doesn't feel like
the worst pop one team either
yeah
so let's let's run through it really
briefly gentlemen we've got a few
comments to uh to get to as well group a
we've got qatar ecuador senegal and the
netherlands group b
uh joe we've got england iran usa and
the european playoff which could be
scotland could be ukraine could be wales
a couple comments at tacotico i love
that name england going down with three
exclamation points that is correct los
blancos 23 england you lost once you'll
lose again that is also correct that is
how it will go and let's make sure that
england have rob green in goal that
would be extra okay with me i have no
problem uh i'm i'm now mesmerized by jj
okocha on the screen graham i'm just
going to throw to you while i watch
digio cocha uh how are you feeling about
this potential group of scotland england
the united states and iran i know
scotland iran the obvious historical
connection there
yeah it's a real rival rivalry that one
between scotland and iran so i should
probably caveat everything i say from
this point on of we need to qualify
still we've got two really difficult
games potentially coming up so we're
we're not there yet so let's just say we
we are in that group and we end up there
and i'm reasonably happy with that group
because i think we showed at the euros
that we can hang with with england
obviously we got a point against them at
wembley and iran in the usa i feel like
we'd be competitive in those games
obviously we are probably the underdogs
in that group but i don't feel like
we're going to get blown off the pitch
by by any of those teams so it's
probably given that we are
one of the weaker if we qualify we will
be one of the weaker teams at the whole
tournament i think it's probably as good
a draw as we as we might have hoped for
without maybe england being qatar or
something like that
what would happen honest question graham
what would happen if scotland and
england play each other in a world cup
like would they have to be
would you have to like like arm the
border very briefly how would it work uh
how much like security would there have
to be
yeah i'm just trying to think through so
we played them at euros we played them
in euro 96 we played them in playoffs we
played them obviously the euros last
summer i am pretty sure
maybe maybe historically in kind of the
maybe the 50s and the 60s we did but
certainly not in modern history we
haven't played them at world cup and by
modern history i mean in like 90s and
80s when scotland used to actually make
world cups so it'd be slightly new
territory and and you're right yeah i
think uh just uh two lots of uh football
hooligans casuals at the border just
joining there and it feels like
something that would happen on the day
of that game
oh i'm so excited uh a few more comments
at d-lane 82 iran can get this american
work too
i like the confidence uh some people
taking issue with england's confidence
at jobo 93 england fans way too
confident already uh at matt glandy
mexico's group looking tough already
andrew q14 brazil have the exact same
group as last world cup brazil serbia
switzerland cameroon so joe a bit of
familiarity there i'm assuming you can
still back brazil to make it through
i would yeah but but that group c i'm
scanning to the groups now fellows and i
want to get your guys's perspective on
this as well
i'm not sure there's a de facto group of
death but as far as which group we think
is strongest because there can be a
strongest group without it being the
group of death most likely group g is is
not easy for any of these teams brazil
of course have the most talent maybe one
of the most talented teams in this
entire tournament coming out of calm
ebola and really dominating for large
stretches of world cup qualifying but
serbia graham did a great job of walking
us through the talent that they have
switzerland of course i mean i i did a
quick hit on them i'm pretty high on
this swiss team
lots of really nice players dennis
zacharia i think obviously just moving
to juve he's incredibly talented and he
showed that in the bundesliga and he
showed it for switzerland in the past
and then cameroon like this is new who's
team i mean come on it doesn't get much
better than this new who is the guy he's
going to be the star of this whole
tournament but i mean on a serious note
i think cameroon and we saw this at
afcon they're they're a legit team like
akanbi graham you talked about him
plenty in the past there's there's real
talent here group g for me might be one
of the most difficult groups if not the
most difficult one here guys do you have
any other shouts for for hardest group
or maybe if you think there is a group
of death
so i don't think there's a group of
death ge definitely as is i think
possibly the strongest but i think h as
well with uh
portugal uruguay korea and a missing one
whose other team in group h
ghana was the other team in age yes so i
feel like that is that's a pretty
competitive
group uruguay there we haven't spoken
about them really in depth
they have transitioned into a new
generation really really effectively
obviously they had um the louis suarez
and edson cavani era that followed on
from
players like diego forland this is a
country of just under four million
people and yet now they're producing
players like darwin nunez the benfica
striker who seems i think he's going to
be a big name in the premier league or
one of the big five european leagues
pretty soon ferry valverde the real
madrid midfielder uh rodrigo benton curd
spurs midfielder ronaldo rajo so uruguay
teams are always
associated with defensive stability and
being good in the air in particular with
players like diego godin well one of
ronald rahul i think is one of the best
young central defenders in europe and
he's very versatile as well he's been
playing right back for barcelona
recently so i look at that uruguay team
and people will be drawn to names like
luis suarez who's still kicking around
but actually when you dig down and look
and look at that that uh that new
generation they're strong as well so
then landing in that group i think makes
that that group very strong very strong
and very formidable too
it is a strange thing when we're looking
at these groups to to know for sure what
the like the strongest to the the middle
the weakest would be because we have
these playoffs that still have to happen
because peru makes group d a really
fascinating uh like potentially
fascinating game peru can be so tricky
but then it could be australia as well
it could be the uae so just kind of not
knowing who exactly it's going to be
makes it hard to know the exact strength
but i think the consensus opinion seems
to be that france got a fairly easy draw
my general feeling is that no draw is
particularly easy when it comes to the
world cup
because france we know have tons of
talent but peru have proven that they
can be a very tricky team and that's a
peru team that historically or at least
in past competitions haven't been able
to have their full strength lineup i
think they could spring a surprise we
know denmark have the talent and ability
and belief to be able to make something
happen tunisia i think going to be one
of those teams that like will be maybe
ignored or not given like the attention
they deserved but it's a very good
tunisia team uh i took a look at them
it's another one where they basically
breezed through qualifying in the sense
that they got four wins one draw one
loss in their group stage games they get
past mali winning their first leg uh one
nil on the road only two goals conceded
throughout qualifying so it's going to
be a strong defensive unit made it to
the quarterfinals of afghan made it to
the final and lost to algeria of the
2021 arab cup there are not a ton of
household names on that squad the one
that i think people might come to know
in the near future would be hannibal
mesuri the 19 year old central attacking
midfielder he makes their 4231 work and
ideally we'll end up playing at some
point for the manchester united senior
team graham i have a trivia question for
you about tunisia they're coached by
tunisian manager jalal khadri who has
had 26 different coaching positions
according to wikipedia wow since he
first started managing how long ago
graham
um
i mean it's got to started in like the
early 90s the mid 90s to have got that
many clubs in am i over shooting you
there
i believe he started coaching in 2002.
he's been running a little bit uh now
baby
[Laughter]
he's he's making moves he's uh jalal
khadri
i was gonna keep going frank de porter i
like that one uh yeah so i think
unless do you all disagree i'm saying
that there isn't like one obviously weak
team is there a candidate for either of
you joe do you have one
uh not yet i mean nothing i'd feel
overly confident about before we dive in
and do our research and we're gonna have
a ton of obviously world cup content out
we'll dive into as the world cup gets
closer more in-depth research on each
and every one of these teams so i don't
want to hedge my bets just yet and look
like a fool when we do those preview
shows there's not there's not an overly
weak team i think you would be very
foolish to to count any team out in this
tournament like these are these are all
very capable teams and as i said earlier
tournament soccer is a leveler it's an
equalizer it turns bad teams into
capable teams and it turns great teams
into mediocre teams on any given day so
that's my one note there the team i will
mention though
we talked about group h in portugal
ghana uruguay and south korea
ghana is not as strong as they've been
and they sneak past nigeria and of
course that's an impressive win in the
two-leg playoff for them to make it into
this competition but they were bossed in
those games by nigeria i mean it's
extremely unfortunate for nigeria that
they're not here similar to the to the
italy north macedonia situation of just
dominating that game and not being able
to finish the job ghana is not really a
team that i'm expecting to give portugal
and uruguay all that much trouble maybe
not even south korea either but again
i'm going to hedge my bets here and not
say too much more because uh i could end
up looking very foolish later on
joe i think that's why it's graham do
you want to go the same route or do or
excuse me graham yeah do you have any
you want to uh spotlight as being weaker
than others
yeah yeah i mean uh similar to joe i
don't i don't want to
put all my money on a certain team being
weaker than the rest before we've done
our research and also the tournament's
like still quite a distance away it
starts in the best oh my gosh we gotta
wait for a lot eight months guys
whatever it is i know so there's still a
lot still a lot can change in that time
but i think i'm not sure which path it
is but one of the intercontinental
um qualification spots as australia uae
and peru and i think
those three teams australia who have um
traditionally been a heavyweight of well
not traditionally because they moved
into afc but recently i've been a
heavyweight of afc have had a really
poor uh qualification campaign
they're struggling with a bit of a
talent problem at the moment there's
questions over the coaching leadership
of that team and they've still got to
get through the the intercontinental
playoff uae
they've not qualified for world cup
since 1990 they have achieved some
success at the asian cup but we're
talking semi-finals and and third place
finishes at the asian cup so not not a
huge amount of pedigree there and and
peru maybe peru of those three are
potentially the strongest they they
finished in the the playoff place and
and calm the ball finished that campaign
pretty strongly i would like to see peru
because the color that they they brought
to the 2018 world cup which was
fantastic it was one of the highlights
of the of the tournament and also the
fact that they've been at a tournament
maybe means they have a slightly more
experience than the other two who
haven't been there recently but yeah
that that intercontinental pathway is
maybe slightly weaker than the rest for
me
few more comments for us to get to at ec
bach says don't count out japan joe and
graham have done just that we will not
count out japan japan still very much in
the world cup still very much uh
involved uh j.h broome 10. oof poland is
tough group c is looking nice that would
be argentina saudi arabia mexico poland
i'm gonna say
early contender for top spot in that one
would be argentina controversial take i
know but then it does feel like it could
be very open for that second place spot
and we always know teams that are
expected to go far can end up crashing
out of the group stage so i guess what
we should all predict is saudi arabia
and poland to make it out of group c joe
that worked for you
yeah yeah that's taylor you read my mind
i don't know how you managed to do that
but yeah
uh a few more at williams 33 x
netherlands are scary for real no
argument there drew baca says joe lowry
always bringing the fire takes uh i
appreciate that i also appreciate that
someone was speculating or asking why
drake bell was on the screen i'm
assuming that was for joe but i also
don't really know enough about drake
bell to know who they might have been
specifically referring to graham does
that name mean anything to you
it could have been a little ryan bailey
i like his tiny manila as well you
managed to get the gold foil in yeah and
that's especially impressive graham how
is ryan feeling before we call it a day
how is he feeling about this draw is he
as smug as i presume
um
yes just smug voice smug noises coming
out of that face yeah as usual yeah
he's saying hold on he's saying why do
we even need to play this tournament
just give england the trophy already
yeah
it's the same old stick with this guy
you know you know what you get i feel
like you've spent too much time with him
because that really does sound like a
thing that ryan bailey might actually
say
and on that note thank you to everybody
who joined us for the world cup draw it
was a little bit chaotic at times
international playoffs make things a
little bit cloudy but i am so excited
for england iran usa and potentially
hopefully maybe scotland gentlemen thank
you so much or one gentleman graham
ruffin the gentleman thank you so much
for taking the time to break down the
draw with me
thank you taylor wrote well i don't know
about you guys but that has actually
made me pretty excited i was like the
draw is when you can start to really
look forward to the tournament and it
will be
upon us uh before we do it
oh i'm so excited uh joe lowry the
outsider the bad boy thank you as well
yeah no taylor thank you you you killed
it like hosting the show is not easy to
do with everything going on you killed
it i'm totally with graham i am now
unbelievably excited for this tournament
it's going to be a long six seven eight
months before this thing gets here
right and we've got more uh shows live
shows here on the vr app we're gonna be
doing the champions league semi-finals
preview uh and then post-game shows the
final as well uh and i think i speak for
everyone when i say we're very excited
to do that we hope the viewers listeners
join us for those but for now thank you
to everyone again for listening for
watching for sticking with us as we
navigated all of our groups we've got
the world cup coming up i cannot wait
hopefully you all can't either we will
be back soon
[Music]